I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance yesterday we received a
magnificent present a present so large
so impressive so monumental as to boggle
the mind and set the heart aflutter yes
my friends we are well on our way to
seeing the usurper Trump brought low to
seeing the restoration of this Republic
to seeing I think the greatest collapse
of our lifetime because you see Special
Counsel Robert Mueller has uncovered a
scandal the likes of which make
Watergate seem like child's play this
evidence shows that Donald J Trump is
more dangerous than Hitler more
dangerous than Stalin more dangerous
than that mobile pet spud somehow used
the wrong shampoo on my cat fluffy
leaving her less cuddly than usual and
reducing me to a quivering ball of
humanity lying prone in my home tears
and urine now you may say that Mueller's
indictment of Paul Manafort Trump's
former campaign manager says nothing
about Trump or his campaign but you do
not have the depth of intellect that
earned me entrance to the prestigious
Cornell College of Agriculture and life
sciences you do not have the nuance to
understand that Mueller just put the
final nail into Trump's political grave
no one does
no one did it ESPN no one did at MSNBC
no one did it Fox sports nut no one did
it espn2
no one did it Current TV it took me a
lifetime to find the political geniuses
at GQ but they understand me and love me
as I deserve to be loved as I deserve to
be loved Donald J Trump you sir are a
liar you sir are a buffoon you sir are
the kind of human being for whom decency
means nothing and for whom the world is
merely a whorehouse of refuse and trash
that somehow turns me on and yet
simultaneously repulses me suffice it to
say Donald J Trump is on his way out to
the big house to the slammer to the
hoosegow to the calaboose to the pokey
to sing-sing and Robert Mueller with my
help and God's will will put him there
if you wish to purchase my new book
Keith is effing crazy this is not a joke
go on over to Amazon now I know there
some criticizing me for mocking Tommy
Lehren I said the Tommy Lehren misused
the flag and some look at my book cover
and say well Keith you also misuse the
flag
I am the flag the flag me the same
amazing resist remove peace i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show ok
so i couldn't all get through i think
through that whole thing without
laughing sorry about that folks but
there is your keith olbermann
impersonation for a halloween hope you
enjoyed it as much as i did writing it
and reading it probably not but tough
it's my show so we have a lot to get to
today we are going to be discussing the
fallout from the amana ford indictment
and from the george papadapolis
capitalist in indictment and he actually
made a plea bargain i'm gonna talk about
whether Trump is gonna be tempted into
firing Robert Mueller the special
counsel I think that would be a very
large mistake we're gonna get to all of
that plus I want to talk a little bit at
length about this insane ad that I
mentioned yesterday from a Latino
victory caucus in Virginia against Ed
Gillespie the Republican candidate for
Virginia governor but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
bull and branch so one of the things
that you actually should spend some
money on is the is the sheet set that
you use to sleep because you're going to
spend in an ordinate number of hours
tonight trying to sleep and tossing and
turning around in those uncomfortable
old bed sheets that's where Boleyn
branch comes in bull and branch makes
the most affordable and high quality
sheets that you can buy they are made
from 100% organic cotton that means bull
and bran sheets not only feel incredible
they also look amazing and they sell
exclusively on lines that means you're
not paying the expensive retail markup
half the price for twice the quality you
will love the sheets try them for full
enough for 30 nights and see for
yourself how much you like them if you
don't like them then you can always
return them for a full refund so it's a
risk-free proposition go to bull and
branch calm today you'll get $50 off
your first set of sheets plus free
shipping when you use promo code Ben
again these sheets are so good that I
will not buy any other type of sheets
acceptable and branch from my own family
as $50 off plus free shipping right now
at bull and branch calm that's bol el
and branch calm promo code Bennigan's
bull and branch calm promo code Ben okay
so I actually want to star
today with the ad that I talked briefly
about yesterday
from the Latino victory caucus in
Virginia and for those who missed it I
want to play it because this is I think
the worst political ad I have ever seen
in my life I mean I think this makes the
Daisy ad the famous days yet from 1964
where LBJ essentially accused Barry
Goldwater of wanting to get the United
States Newt it makes that ad look like
nothing I mean this is really an
egregious ad so for those who can't see
you're about to see a bunch of minority
children who are who are running away
from a truck that has on it a
confederate flag they don't tread on me
license plate and an Ed Gillespie bumper
sticker because the truck is going to
run them over because it's a white
supremacist seeking to kill minority
children
[Music]
so Latino kid stops and then he sees an
asian kid and then both of them start
running because here comes that truck
again
ed gillespie bumper sticker on it every
racially diverse child in Virginia is on
this block and here they've been running
away from the from the truck and oh no
they've run into a dead end the truck
suddenly it's night and the headlights
come up and all the kids wake up from
their terrible dream is this what Donald
Trump and Ed Gillespie meet and then
it's a picture of the people of the
parents watching the Charlottesville
hate rally and says reject hate vote
November reject hate vote November 7th
and paid for a Latino victory fund it's
not authorized by the candidate but
obviously the candidate did not condemn
it the reason that I'm playing this ad
again is because it really does speak to
the insanity that has now engulfed huge
parts of the left you know the great
conflicts in American history have
largely been driven not just by
political differences but by the feeling
that those political differences are not
are not where we are unable to overcome
those political differences that we hate
each other right there the actual hate
in this ad is not from Ed Gillespie
right the actual hate in this ad is from
this Latino victory fund it's from the
campaign for Ralph Northam who actually
you know if he didn't give the go-ahead
to the ad which would've been illegal he
obviously hasn't condemned the ad and
there was another mailer that actually
went out from the northern campaign
endorsed by the northern campaign
linking again Ed Gillespie
to what happened in Charlottesville
Virginia it's really pretty horrific
stuff when when I read Federalist one
yesterday and I talked about how
Alexander Hamilton had specifically
cited the idea that in politics you have
to assume the best intentions on the
part of your opponent if you want to
convince them we're no longer in the age
of convincing we're now in the age of
getting out your base and I think that
that's a political truism I think that
people missed that in 2012 but in 2016 I
think people got that that it was all
about getting out the base no more was
it no one was trying to appeal to the
median voter now it's just about getting
out the people who already like you and
the best way to get them out is to
essentially say that your opponent is
evil and horrible and nasty and terrible
but if you do this too much if you rely
on this tactic too much you actually end
up telling Americans that the people
that they live with in their same
community are evil horrible nasty
brutish people and if you do that it's
very hard to put the country back
together again because I can have
conversations with people with whom I
disagree I do it all the time for a
living I do it all the time casually I
live in LA I mean this stuff happens but
I don't actually think the people I live
with in LA and the individuals with whom
I speak are nasty horrible people I
think they may believe bad things that
are bad but I don't believe they're
nasty evil people this ad essentially
suggests that people who disagree with
you are nasty evil people again it falls
into the intersectional politics you
want you want an example of
intersectional politics at its finest
this is the example of intersectional
politics at its finest right this idea
that you're gonna have all of these
various minority groups and they're all
running away from the evil white
majority that is chasing them down on
streets it's it's really a horrific ad
and that's not the only evidence that we
have of that over the last 24 hours
Elliot Hamilton reporter for Daily wire
he got ahold of an email that was issued
by a woman apparently named Madeline
leader she is the head of data services
for the technology department at the DNC
and she wrote this letter she was trying
to search people out for four jobs she
said a bit more than just the messenger
here but we in the technology department
here at the DNC are looking to hire for
the following positions and then she
lists a bunch of positions then she says
as you may have heard we are rebuilding
the technology team into a robust
well-oiled machine that can tackle all
elections from the presidential down to
dog catcher and school board what's more
important is that we are focused on
hiring and maintaining a staff of
diverse voices and life experiences
something that we desperately need if we
hope to secure the future of our
countries and they're not just trying to
hire a data science lead or a full stack
engineer or a product designer they're
trying to hire a staff of diverse voices
and life experiences because you know
when your computer crashes what you
really need is somebody coming in and
explaining to you how they grew up poor
in in an inner city that's that's really
really important I know in my computer
crashes the first thing I do when I call
our IT guy is I say to him please tell
me the story of your life and how you're
diverse experiences have led you to the
point where you can fix my mac no that's
not how any of this works but that's how
I'm the bad part here's what the email
apparently says according madellaine
leader again the data the the Democratic
National Committee data service manager
who gave in no comments daily wire when
we asked her about it she said please
let me know if you have any questions or
concerns and feel free to for it on to
your contacts I personally would prefer
that you not forward to cisgender
straight white males since they're
already in the majority
she says straight out in the email that
she doesn't want this email forwarded to
people who happen to be straight and
white because they're already in the
majority it's that same sort of
intersectional logic that leads to the
idea that we can gauge your value as a
human being we can gauge your worthiness
in the workplace by your color by your
life experiences as opposed to by the
quality of work you do or by the kind of
activity in which you take place again
the slander in that Latino victory ad
the slander that everyone implies a
confederate flag is trying to run down
black children which is insane I mean
they're legitimately hundreds of
thousands of Americans we're not doing
that and have Confederate flags the idea
that everyone is voting for Ed Gillespie
size with the charlottesville hate
protesters the idea that anyone who has
it don't tread on me on the front of
their car that that person is trying to
run down some poor Muslim child on the
streets of Alexandria
it's just insane but again it comes from
the same intersectional place that this
white majority is inevitably imbued with
a nasty horrible racism that cannot be
fixed and as long as we think that as
long as the left keeps doing that
they're gonna get pushback from the
other side right that Trump was a
symptom of this you want to know one of
the reasons why Trump won one of the
reasons why Trump won is because
Americans got sick and tired of being
told that they were the types of people
who are trying to drive people down and
Hillary's deplorable lines was the worst
thing she could have said during that
campaign because when she said
deplorable she may have been referring
to the all right but instead she paints
it with a broad brush said half of all
Trump supporters were members of the all
right that of course was untrue well
what this leads to is a is a an insane
amount of doubt in our institutions
because we no longer trust the
institution's we no longer trust the
people who staff our institutions now we
look at the motivations of the people
who staff our institutions and we say
are these people well motivated or not
or is everything a partisan battle and
that's why I think what happens in the
in the mana Ford indictment or the
Papadopoulos situation all of that is
gonna have bearing on how Trump thinks
Trump is an oppositional thinker he
tends to think that people are out to
get him by nature and in many cases he
is right right now I don't think that
Muller actually has them in the
crosshairs I'll explain why in a second
I actually don't think the Mueller is is
going to be able to make a case against
President Trump I think the worst-case
scenario for president Trump is this
ends up looking a lot like a Ron contra
or the guy at the top is basically wet
off the hook and some underlings go go
down but with all of that
Trump could be convinced to fire Robert
Mueller and really create a political
firestorm for himself by people
whispering into his ear that everyone is
out to get him I'm gonna explain all of
that in just a second plus what Tony
Podesta and Hillary Clinton and
everybody else have to do with this
why is DC so darn corrupt I'll explain
in just a second first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at the
u.s. ECA so you would do whatever it
takes to protect their family somebody
try to break in your house in the middle
of the night
you go to your gun safe you take out
your shotgun and if somebody tried to
break in you would blow them away but
owning a gun for protection should not
be intimidating overwhelming or
confusing even in light of the fact that
one mistake could land you with a
mountain of legal fees a lifetime behind
bars bars are worse it's you're right
tonig on its your right to use it
properly that's why I work with the US
ECA to give my listeners they're
complete concealed carry and family
defense Guide 100% free it is 164 pages
of life-saving information you can't
find anywhere else they'll help you
understand confusing gun laws
responsibly owned and store a gun
particularly if you have small kids
trained for real-life scenarios survive
the murky waters of the legal system and
a lot more go to defend my family now
calm right now to begin your simple
rewarding journey to concealed carry and
home defense confidence and right now
you'll also get the complete audio
version and bonus home defense checklist
100% free go to defend my family now
calm again let's defend my family now
come for free instant access to fend my
family now calm gives you the
information that you need to protect and
defend your family so to recap in very
brief terms yesterday's news there are
basically two big pieces of news first
was Trump former campaign chair Paul
Manafort was in charge of the campaign
for something like five months Paul
Manafort was indicted on 12 counts
virtually all of them had nothing to do
while all of them had nothing to do with
Trump and the vast majority of them had
nothing to do with even the period in
which mana fort was working for Trump
and the White House essentially said as
much for Sarah Huckabee Sanders saying
that yesterday but look today's
announcement has nothing to do with the
president has nothing to do with the
president's campaign or campaign
activity the real collusion scandal as
we've said several times before has
everything to do with the Clinton
campaign Fusion GPS and Russia and she
of course is is at least partially
correct the idea the only scandal here
is fusion GPS and Russia
is not true okay the fact is that there
is some other material to Donald Trump
jr. letters the George papadopolis stuff
that it's troubling
so the Trump campaign in nature the
Trump White House more specifically is
doing what they're supposed to do right
they're saying George papadopolis was a
low-level staffer who had nothing to do
with anything he's really not in charge
of anything in the campaign and and so
they're now minimizing his presence in
the campaign just as they did with
Carter Paige who's also a foreign policy
adviser with connections to the Russians
it was extremely limited it was a
volunteer position and again no activity
was ever done in an official capacity on
behalf of the campaign and never been
what about the outreach to these making
the campaign officials to try to put
together this you mean that the outreach
that was repeatedly denied and we're not
gonna take any action on that how can
you describe Papadopoulos as having a
limited role when there's a there's a
photograph of mr. Papadopoulos sitting
at a table with millions of people so
okay and she's not wrong about this
again the idea that Trump was sitting
there trying to direct from the top
George papadopolis seems kind of
ridiculous here's the problem with
regard to Papadopoulos so basically to
recap Papadopoulos was making some sort
of entrees to the professor right not
the guy from Gilligan's Island a
professor who is located in London who
apparently had connections with the
Russian government and was trying to fix
up the Trump campaign with the Russians
and Papadopoulos is trying to make this
happen the Russians also told him they
had access to thousands of Hillary
emails or thousands of emails more
specifically and they said also that
they had dirt on Hillary Clinton
Papadopoulos apparently tried to pass
this up the chain and this was shut down
it's now coming out that some of the
people he talked to included Paul
Manafort
he was basically he was gonna be
indicted on charges of lying to the FBI
about the extent to which he had been
working with the Trump campaign while he
was making these connections and instead
he pled guilty in order so that he could
basically get out of it there's there's
some rumors today the Papadopoulos may
have been wearing the wire the federal
government turned him and that the he
was wearing a wire and in context of all
the the other Trump officials we're
gonna have to find that out but having
read the Papadopoulos statement of the
offense I can say with certainty that
there is nothing in there
that is significantly more damning for
example then that Donald Trump jr.
letters that Trump jr. released himself
on Twitter where he basically said that
he was willing to hear the Russians had
about hurt on Hillary and again
Huckabee Sanders and the rest of the
Trump team they're not wrong to say that
Hillary Clinton was willing to do the
same thing in that fusion GPS dossier so
in the end I don't think any of this
really touches Trump I don't think this
reaches all the way to the top Manta
force lawyers is saying also there's no
there's no evidence of collusion and
he's right I mean the indictment doesn't
contain any evidence of collusion
between Manta fort and the Russians with
regards of the campaign specifically
there's no evidence that mr. Madoff or
or the Trump campaign colluded with the
Russian government mr. Madoff or
represented pro-european Union campaigns
for the Ukrainian and in that he was
seeking to further democracy and to help
the Ukraine come closer to the United
States and the EU okay so you know again
I think there's a bit of a of a
benevolent spin on what manna fort was
doing but the evidence simply is not
there Trump's own lawyer Rhett Jay
Sekulow he's saying that Trump is not
interested in firing Mueller the only
thing that can damage Trump in my
opinion here the only thing that will
really hurt him is if he fires Mueller
there are two things that Trump can do
that will start a political firestorm in
the midst of all of this one of them I
think would be justifiable one I think
would be unjustifiable the thing that he
could do that would be justifiable is to
tell his attorney general to open up a
Special Counsel investigation into
Hillary Clinton infusion GPS to see if
there was actual collusion taking place
now Eli Lake has a really good piece
over a Bloomberg view and when she talks
about the fact that because Hillary
basically used lawyers as go-betweens
and shows both plausible deniability as
well as a chain of payment and it wasn't
like a gift from the Russian government
because of that there may not be any
laws violated but certainly an
investigation would be a worthwhile
thing Trump could do that it would start
a firestorm it look like he's trying to
misdirect from the Mueller episode I'm
not sure to be politically smart even
though it revved his base up for sure on
the other hand when he could do that
could really hurt him his firing Mueller
if he fires Mueller based on suspicion
that Mueller is gonna do something it
will look more like a cover-up than like
a legitimate exercise of presidential
power even though he does have the power
as president of the United States to
fire the special counsel the Independent
Counsel law expired in the late 90s that
was the law that allowed Kenneth Starr
to basically operate free of being fired
by President Clinton both parties said
this is no good we can't have
independent counsels who are running
around willy-nilly doing whatever they
want without being subject to being
fired by either Congress or the
executive branch so they let that law
expire now special counsels can be fired
by the president but if Trump would have
fired the special counsel and if you
were to do so on the basis that the
special counsel was looking at his
family finances for example which he
said he doesn't want Mueller to do or if
he were to fire Mueller on the basis
that Mueller is is going too far into
his investigations of Trump personally
it would look like a coverup and it
would create a not a constitutional
crisis because it would be
constitutional but would create a
political crisis for Trump you create
the appearance that he's firing Mueller
in order to avoid being being convicted
of something right now in order to be
avoid being investigated or it protects
his family members and there are people
encouraging him to do this so Trump's
lawyer Jay Sekulow is doing the right
thing here he's saying I don't think
Trump is gonna fire me learn he has no
intention of doing so no I do know in
fact yeah I saw a couple people talking
about that this morning and and the
answer to that is no the president has
not is not interfering with the special
counsel Mahler's position he's not
firing the special counsel he said that
before
there's no the fact that I don't think
that anybody is surprised that an
indictment came down today
or that there was this play because we
expected this indictment I mean I think
I've been on your broadcast talking
about this a couple months back okay now
all of that Lee says there is exactly
correct John Kelly Trump's chief of
staff he says the same thing he says let
the indictments work let's see where the
legal system works and let the system do
what it's supposed to do all of the
activities as I understand it that they
were indicted for was long before they
ever met Donald Trump or or had any
association with the campaign but I
think the reaction of the administration
is let the legal justice system work
everyone's innocent until resumed
innocent and we'll see where it goes
okay and that exactly would be the right
thing to do right you should just let
this thing roll out unfortunately I
think that there are forces on the left
and forces on the right that are
basically trying to troll Trump into
firing Mueller because once he fires
Mueller then there is going to be an
accusation that he fired him for the
same reason that he's supposedly fired
call me because
was getting too close now as I said all
along I think the real reason that Trump
fired Comey is he wanted to Comey to
come out publicly and exonerate Trump
Comey wasn't willing to do that because
Comey said if I exonerate you now and
then you come under investigation later
then I'm gonna have to say so and Trump
didn't like that so he fired call me
well the same thing could easily happen
with Mueller where he goes to Mueller
and says listen I want you to exonerate
me and Mueller says well I can't yet and
Trump says you're fired if that happens
it will look like a cover-up of epic
proportions and it will lead the
Democrats not only to try and impeach
him if they gain control of the house in
2018 but we'll put Republicans in a
tough spot too these will look a lot
more like the Saturday night massacre
under Richard Nixon then it'll look like
him just firing somebody who deserves to
be fired as I say they're people on both
right and left or trying to troll him
into this
Steve Bannon apparently is trying to
troll Trump into firing Robert Mueller
that's because Bannon has more balls
than brains I'll explain that in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at stamps comso
stamps you know our the the only way
that you can send your mail but you
don't want to wait in line at the post
office well I don't like waiting in line
at the post office because I don't like
wasting time as much as I enjoy the the
wonderful smells and sights of the post
office I would much rather not go and
simply be able to print my postage off
onto my mail directly and then put it in
the mail slot and be done well that's
what stamps comm allows you to do I can
mail in any letter any package using
just my computer and printer and the
mailman picks it right up
stamps.com never closes so you don't
have to worry about it gotta get there
before 5:00 it print postage for letters
or packages at your convenience 24/7 it
is convenient it is easy it is reliable
and it is flexible they bring you all
the services of the US Postal Service
right to your fingertips again you can
buy in prints official US postage for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your computer and printer and they
will even send you a digital scale
automatically calculating your exact
postage they don't have to estimate it
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs I use stamps comm because I don't
have time to run out to the post office
every day and we here at the at the
office use stamps comm for exactly the
same reason right now you can try the
stamps comm service with the special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus postage and a digital scale without
long term commitments go to stamps comm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Shapiro that
stamps comm promo code Shapiro again
there's a microphone at the top of the
page click it hit your PIN and type in
Shapiro now we'll give you a four week
trial plus postage and the digital scale
without long term commitments pretty
awesome stamps calm never go to the post
office again okay so as I say there are
some folks on the right who are trying
to tell Trump to fire Mueller and there
are some folks on the left or trying to
tell Trump to fire Mueller I think that
some people on the right who are trying
to tell Trump to fire Mueller are trying
to get in good with Trump they
understand the easiest way to earn
Trump's respect and his good grace is to
suggest a Trump that he has ultimate
power
right like Jafar at the end of of
Aladdin the ultimate power in the
universe
itty-bitty living space the problem is
that you know people like Bannon who are
telling Trump obstruct Muller don't give
him any documents try to stop him
because he's out of control you do that
it's gonna come out it's gonna look like
you're trying to obstruct and then you
have a political problem on your hands
whereas you just say listen my doors are
wide open I have nothing to hide it
makes it very difficult for the left to
claim that this Trump Russia collusion
stuff is a reality folks on the left are
desperately hoping against hope that
Muller has the evidence to go against
Trump but again I don't think he does
you know Laura Ingraham said this last
night she said that if Muller had
anything on Trump he would hit with that
first I think that that may or may not
be true but I don't see based on the
manna for indictment unless it's just an
attempt to get manna for it to flip how
this reflects on Trump I have always
thought that if if there was any sort of
collusion inside the Trump campaign it
wasn't because Trump was sitting atop
the campaign directing it is because
trumpet said I wanted to be close to the
Russians I liked Putin I hate Hillary
and so some low-level staffer says okay
he doesn't like he likes Putin he
doesn't like Hillary what if we just go
to Putin and help from take out Hillary
it seems to me that this could very
easily be a case of Henry the second
well no one rid me of this meddlesome
priest and and that would be the easiest
answer here but that would not
necessarily be the actually that that
wouldn't actually be Trump directing
this from above again I think both the
right and the left though are trying to
kind of push Trump into using that gun
that's over the mantelpiece you know
there's this old rule in drama it's a is
a rule from check off the player I check
off that when you put a gun over the
mantelpiece in the first act it must be
used by the end of the second act well
the gun over the mantelpiece is firing
Mueller and I have a feeling that Trump
is going to be tempted to do it just
because that's what Trump has been
tempted
again the only audacious movies made as
president really is firing Comey which
blew back on him which should be a good
example not to do this
leon panetta obviously a matter of left
he says that more indictments are coming
again democrats are gonna keep saying
this and keep saying this hoping they
can't rip trump into firing Mueller's
that then they can go after him on that
basis as opposed to the actual
underlying supposed crime what these
indictments may indicate is that as a
result of it there will be other trails
of evidence that will be followed by bob
muller and i think there's probably a
very good bet that additional
indictments will be forthcoming and
could involve members of both parties
okay well I think that that last point
is the really important one okay the
person one of the people who who was
basically called on the carpet or is
going to be called on the carpet is Tony
Podesta Tony Podesta is the brother of
John Podesta very very close to the
Clintons the Podesta group was founded
by the Podesta brothers to lobbying
group inside Washington DC they worked
very closely with Paul Manafort in his
sort of pro-ukrainian dealings from 2006
to 2014 and in doing so Podesta got
himself into some hot water the same day
that the man afford indictment came down
Tony Podesta has now resigned from the
Podesta group he's resigned because he's
got to imagine that something is coming
down the pike for him well this should
tempt Trump to basically hold his fire
because of people from both sides get
indicted it's gonna look like what it is
this is the swamp it's not gonna look
like Trump it's gonna look like the
swamp Trump's best move here is to hold
his fire unfortunately Steve ban and
being more balls than brains is telling
him not to do that ban and apparently
according to The Daily Beast spoke on
the phone with Trump on Monday offered a
message get yourself some new lawyers
now listen I know Bannon pretty well I
was on a phone call with him twice a day
for an hour a day for an hour a call for
two years so I know bannon's tendencies
bannon's tendencies is always honey
badger right honey badger that's honey
badger that this is not a situation
where the honey badger is going to be
successful because the fact is the more
you dig in here the more the Democrats
actually have something to play with
according to The Daily Beast the former
White House chief strategist has grown
increasingly concerned the president's
legal team is falling down on the job
proving too accommodating to Robert
Mueller leaving trum venerable as former
campaign aides are handed indictments in
terms of Steve's thinking about how the
president is handling this yeah he
thinks the legal team was not prepared
for what happened today there
serving the president well a source
close to Bannon said another confidant
abandon believes Ty Cobb and John's out
the top two attorneys on the president's
legal team are quote asleep at the wheel
apparently two sources inside and
outside the White House with knowledge
of a conversation between Trump and
Bannon told The Daily Beast been advised
from not to demote doubt in Cobb but to
bring in new lawyers to work over them
in the hopes that fresh blood would
bring an order and ruthlessness to
Trump's legal team that Bannon sees is
desperately incompetent and doubt in
Cobb have both said that they should
cooperate with the Mueller investigation
and and both cobb and Dowd have had
their problems but the idea that you're
gonna fix this by basically stonewalling
is the biggest mistake that you can make
stonewalling here again if Trump is
really in a sense I think that
stonewalling is probably the worst thing
that he can do and and I'll give you an
example of this right Tony Podesta steps
down from the Podesta group and he is
talked about by Tucker Carlson on Fox
News well Venable which is a very very
good national law firm they sent a
letter to Tucker Carlson and they
basically threatened Tucker Carlson to
stop talking about this is it gonna help
Tony Podesta to do this the answer is no
here's Carlson talking about it we got a
letter from Jeff Garin thir he's a
lawyer with Venable LLP a big law firm
here in DC the letter demands that this
show quote immediately cease and desist
disseminating false and misleading
reports about mr. Podesta in the Podesta
group it demands we retract and delete
all our prior reporting in the Podesta
group and warns that if we don't do this
quote mr. Podesta may pursue legal
action including for damages in order to
fully protect his rights the letter
doesn't stop there though it also warns
us that we will face legal action under
the Copyright Act merely for quoting
from this letter publicly as we just did
the most amusing line though is this one
quote Paul Manafort did not work with
the Podesta group in this representation
of the European Center for a modern
Ukraine that's what the lawyers letters
pulled us
apparently that lawyer hasn't read the
Manafort indictment yet
in paragraph 22 of that indictment we
read this quote at the direction of
Manafort and gates companies a and B
engaged in extensive lobbying on Ukraine
the indictment also says that the
Podesta group and Mercury were selected
personally by Paul Manafort to lobby on
behalf of Ukrainian interests so
stonewalling in other words is the worst
thing that you can do here because if
you stonewall it's just gonna lead to
more information being disseminated like
tucker carlson did correctly last night
on his program so this is a mistake the
way that Trump should play this the way
that Trump should play this first of all
let me just say this the person who is
most in agreement with me on this is
Alan Dershowitz the harvard law
professor who i actually had at harvard
law and he says that he doesn't think
that new lords gonna quote unquote get
Trump I think this is correct his
indictment has everything to do with
Trump they never would have indicted him
for money laundering or tax evasion if
he weren't somebody who they thought
could turn on Trump could provide
information and evidence if not Trump
somebody higher up in the chain between
Manta for and Trump this is dominoes you
knock down the first domino that knocks
down the second domino ultimately what
Muller is aiming for is the big domino
in the Oval Office I don't think they're
gonna get him I don't think they have
anything because collusion even if it
were to be established isn't a crime
that's correct as I've said before
collusion is not in fact a crime you
actually have to engage in conspiracy in
order for you to achieve a crime none of
that is real and so the best thing that
Trump can do is sort of open his arms
and say bring it at me you know come at
me bro right that's that sort of the
best thing he can do especially because
as I'm about to explain the the Trump
can actually turn this whole thing to
its advantage I'm explain how Trump can
turn this whole thing to his advantage
but for that you're gonna have to
subscribe to the podcast if you want to
watch me talk about it live so for $9.99
a month you can get the rest of this
show live on video you can always listen
to us later of course and you can always
watch our Facebook free and YouTube free
section of the video later but if you
want to have the whole show on video
then you have to down you have to
download it and stream it by subscribing
at $9.99 a month to daily why're you got
my sure you get a Knowles's show you get
you get kleavon's show you get all of
those things Clavin is not dressing up
today I believe that Knowles is
and it should be pretty horrific if
Knowles holds true to form so check that
out I'm also if you want the annual
subscription $99 a year it gets the
annual subscription which comes complete
with this leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler the greatest of all vessels
holding beverages
it holds the brew that is true as they
say in the court jester
so leftists here's hot or cold mug you
get that when you subscribe annually
please subscribe to our youtube channel
as well because we always have cool new
kind of cultural content coming out and
if you want to subscribe just to the
audio go to SoundCloud or iTunes or
Spotify or any of the various
downloading apps and subscribe and leave
us a comment and review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so here's her I think that the President
Trump can turn all of this to his
advantage I think the way he can turn
this to his advantage is by pointing out
what he's always been pointing out which
is the swamp now the problem is that the
swamp also encompasses a lot of his
lower downs and what Trump should do and
this is what Trump Trump fans are gonna
have to swallow hard here and accept a
reality Donald Trump is not playing for
tea-chest Donald Trump is not playing
underwater mega mega mega upside down
Hungry Hungry Hippos okay he's not doing
any of those things Donald Trump even if
you like him even if thing is well
motivated man he is not a sophisticated
player in this space
okay the lie that who's gonna come in
and clean everything up because he was
just so sophisticated business player
knew the ins and outs had bribed people
all this it's just not true okay the
most the best case you can make for
president Trump if you are a Trump
supporter right now is saying that Trump
came in here and it turns out that even
during his campaign the swamp was
basically trying to infiltrate his
campaign and trying to infect his
campaign with swamp eNOS right manna
fort was a Republican insider long
before long before President Trump had
ever been on the political horizon again
I told you I was made aware of manna for
being kind of a swamp creature back in
like 2012-2013 and he was working deeply
with the RNC at the time when he's close
with the Bush's the idea that that manna
fort was some sort of trump specific
pick who was personally close to Trump
is not true probably what happened is
that people at the RNC said you know who
you could use you could use Paul
Manafort and he said okay sure Manta
fort why not what he should be saying is
listen all these people who are
recommended to me by the RNC all these
people who are recommended to me about
the Republican insiders these are the
people who are involved in the swamp you
want to know how I know because look how
manifold was working with Podesta right
Podesta is a part of the swamp too these
are all part of the swamp now the one
thing about this that I like
particularly is that it is true okay it
is true that Washington DC is filled
with swamp creatures now the reason the
Washington DC however is filled with
swamp creatures is not because we just
elected the worst people invariably very
often people we elect are good people
the problem is that the swamp eats
people because the swamp is in and of
itself just a swamp of money can we say
the swamp people think oh well look at
all that corruption all these corrupt
people if we just elected the right
people then that would fix everything
I'm a believer in the Milton Friedman
line it's not about electing the right
people it's about getting the wrong
people to do the right thing and that
means you have to minimize
the power in Washington DC all of the
swamp penis right and it does it engulfs
both parties and involves people in both
campaigns all of this is because
Washington DC is so powerful because
Washington DC has so much money in it
because there are so many people who are
seeking to take advantage of that wealth
and power in Washington DC I'm gonna
give you a list of names of people who
have basically been implicated in all of
this okay manna fort okay Hillary
Clinton Tony Podesta Donald Trump jr.
Christopher steel James Comey George
papadopolis Jeff Sessions Rod Rosenstein
right there's like everyone everyone has
been implicated in something here that
is not good and is swampy in some way
and the reason for that is not because
all these people are bad it's not
because all these people are evil people
it's not because they all have bad
intent it's because the people who are
drawn to Washington DC the people who
are drawn to power tend to be the people
who most want to take advantage of the
money in power the only way to stop this
swamp enos is to cut Washington DC down
to the bone now I don't know that
President Trump is willing to do that
but if he were this would be the perfect
time to say this the perfect time to say
this would be right now you look at all
this look at all this corruption you
know manna Ford had no idea who the guy
was he came in he ran my campaign for a
while I really brought him on for
delegate stuff which is probably true
when I found out about all the Russia
stuff then I fired him which is also
true you know I'm not here to be
participate in the swamp but I have to
admit that being an ignoramus about this
sort of stuff it was pretty easy to
infiltrate my campaign and this is one
of the problems that we need to solve by
minimizing the power of Washington DC
that would require Trump to say that
he's made mistakes before it would
require Trump fans to say that he's made
mistakes before but it seems to me
that's the best tactic and can actually
be used as a positive for President
Trump going forward okay time for some
things I like things I hate and then
we'll deconstruct the culture for a
moment okay so things I like I've been
doing books for parents because I was
asked about it last week so this book is
called the happiest baby on the block
my Harvey Karp so yesterday I gave you
sort of a guide to dealing with toddlers
because I have a three and a half year
old and you know disciplining toddlers a
difficult thing this one is about how to
get some sleep when you're a parent the
happiest baby on the block is basically
about very very small babies right
newborns how do you come crying and help
your newborn baby sleep longer
it's become basically the the Holy Writ
when it comes to combing newborn babies
they call them the five SS and I won't
get them all off the top of my head but
its swaddling and shush Inge and
swinging and this is what you do to a
baby that won't stop crying carps theory
is that there's no such thing as colic
that the idea that there's a colicky
baby who's just crying and crying and
crying because don't stop crying he
thinks that if you use these methods it
comes the baby pretty quickly I've used
it on both my children it definitely
works checkout the happiest baby on the
block by Harvey Karp there's also a
little documentary that you can view
online where Karp actually shows you how
to do these techniques to get your baby
to stop crying he can finally get some
slaves to check that out okay other
things that I like so this is pretty
incredible Hillary Clinton was asked
what she's gonna dress as for Halloween
and she said she would quote go as the
president really that's what she said
she said that she would go as the
president which led me to ask well why
would she dress his Donald Trump that's
weird
first of all that would be a great that
would be a great thing if Hillary
Clinton were to dress his Donald Trump I
don't think she's actually going to do
it
Hillary Clinton at this point has
basically become Miss Havisham from
Dickens she was jilted at the altar
thirty years ago and now she still walks
around learning or wedding dress and
that's her shtick now so here she was
doing that yesterday she was asked about
these indictments and Hillary says well
guys I have a great chapter on
indictments in my book please buy my
book please please keep me relevant
[Applause]
I have a great chapter about Russia in
here she's still trying to show her
books here there's one thing she will
never be in that of course as presidents
of the United States what a charmer she
is I can't believe she's not president
okay other things that I like so Bryan
Cranston it's very rare to run across
actors who are not so eaten by the
Hollywood machine that they don't feel
the necessity to go out there and just
rip Trump up and down every five minutes
Bryan Cranston is one of these maybe
it's because he's sort of late to the
ball game right he was a comedic actor
until he did Breaking Bad and now he's
probably one of the most sought-after
actors in Hollywood he came out and he
said listen people who are rooting for
Trump to fail essentially screw you guys
say he said if you if you think that you
know Trump should fail here here's what
he said let me get the direct quote
according to The Hollywood Reporter he
said if he fails the country's in
jeopardy it would be egotistical for
anyone to say I hope he fails so that
person oh hey fu why would you want that
so you can be right I don't want him to
fail I want to succeed I do I honestly
do and if you got a good idea that helps
the country oh man I'm gonna support you
I don't care if you're a Republican I'm
a Democrat or whatever I don't care
a good idea is a good idea now this
harkens back to right after Obama was
elected and Rush Limbaugh said he wanted
Obama to fail what he meant by that is
he wanted Obama's policies to fail he
wanted Obama to hidden want Obama's he
didn't want bad outcomes for the country
he wanted Obama to fail in implementing
his policies but I think that Cranston's
comments here go to something deeper
which is people have a personal
investment in Donald Trump personally
failing and that's a problem I agree
with him and good for Cranston for
saying it okay time for a quick thing I
hate
okay so today is the thing I hate John
Kelly the chief of staff has become more
and more sort of openly political I
think there's a mistake by John Kelly I
think John Kelly I had the love and
respect of a vast majority of Americans
the chief of staff because of his
military service is great career the
fact that he's a gold star father and
now it seems like he's getting more and
more political and when he does so he's
mirroring the Trump line on a lot of
topics sometimes that's good and
sometimes what he's doing is true but
he's getting himself in trouble I'm not
sure this is his best use to the
President of the United States is going
out there and speaking on things like
removal of Confederate monuments now cuz
I disagree with him about the
Confederate monument removal but because
his job is to act as a a shield for
President Trump not to act as a sword
for for Trump's rhetoric in any case he
was on with Laura Ingraham last night
launching her news show and here's what
he had to say it shows you what how much
of a lack of appreciation of history and
what history is I would tell you that
robert e lee was an honorable man he was
a man that gave up gave up his country
for his state which in 150 years ago was
more important than country it was
always loyalty to state first back in
those days now where it's different
today but the the lack of an ability to
compromise led to the Civil War and men
and women of good faith on both sides
made their stand where their conscience
had them make their stand
so people are basically ripping him up
and down for that last comment about the
Civil War that robert e lee was an
honorable man that people made stands of
conscience on both sides and they're
trying to suggest that he's a racist
because of this watch Ken Burns's
documenting Ken Burns basically says a
lot of these same things this wasn't
until the last five to ten years sort of
the way that the Civil War history was
taught when I was in middle school this
is where the Civil War was taught not
just that it was about slavery but there
were people who are arguing on behalf of
states rights disconnected from slavery
and didn't hold slaves and didn't even
particularly like slavery this was this
was sort of commonplace teaching that
may be wrong right and maybe that the
revisionist history is correct this was
all about slavery that Lee was not an
honorable guy that he was fighting on
behalf of a treasonous cause and that
the entire thing was it was about
slavery from beginning to end
that seems to me in many ways more
historically accurate than the
traditional way this has been taught but
to suggest that Kelly's a racist because
of this is to be ignorant of how the
Civil War has largely been taught in
American schools for the last hundred
and fifty years and now again I think
his last line there that the Civil War
happened because failure to compromise
I'm not sure how you compromised with
slavery exactly
obviously Lincoln tried actually Lincoln
wanted to to try and cut some sort of
deal
Republicans had been trying to cut some
sort of deal even though their
abolitionists but that failed because
the the South basically could not accept
the results of the 1860 election okay
time to deconstruct the culture a little
bit so in deconstructing the culture
what we like to do is we'd like to take
a piece of culture that maybe you are
listening to your kids are listening to
your friends are listening to and talk
about what exactly the message is in the
culture this one is kind of subtle
there's a very very catchy song out by a
group called Portugal of the man I guess
that it's the name of the group is based
on some obscure thing about how they
felt like more than one person so there
one man and also a country but they
picked Portugal at random and in case
band names are basically come out the
band names are basically just segments
from a James Joyce novels like
Finnegan's Wake they just pick a phrase
and then that becomes the name of the
band any case the song is called feel it
still it's a very catchy song but
there's something going on in the music
video that if you didn't know about it
you're not going to catch
[Music]
okay so what's weird about this this
particular music video aside from the
fact that it's a weird music video is
the fact that they actually embedded
Easter eggs throughout the music video
so you'd have to watch it online but you
can actually click in the middle of the
music video and it puts out messages so
the people who design it right the band
actually said they wanted it to be a
rallying cry for politics they said that
they wanted this to be a song for the
resistance so you can listen to it and
not get that it's a song for the
resistance right basically they're
saying that you know you you feel the
lyric is all about how they're
supposedly apathetic but they can still
feel the resistance of 66 and say I'm a
rebel just for kicks now I've been
feeling it since 1966 now the ideas
they're still part of this Woodstock
generation that's why the album is
called Woodstock so the left has never
gotten over this idea like it stop it
right there actually if you go back to
that particular freeze screen of the
people making out in the car if you were
to click on the freeze screen of the
people making out in the car maybe an
Easter egg actually pops up when you
click on it and it's it's a direction to
Planned Parenthood so that's an example
there's also a direction to give money
to the ACLU or to help refugees and so
they've embedded all these political
messages so right there's a sort of
random shot of people making out in a
car if you click on this then it gives
you the direct contact information for
the it gives you the direct contact
information for Planned Parenthood so
this is the way that that Hollywood sees
it's making a difference and this is why
when people in Hollywood say we're just
out there to make money we're just
appealing to the population no they feel
the necessity to actually push a
particular message and everybody's
living this afterglow from the 1960s the
1960s happened literally 50 years ago
now folks 50 years ago okay the 1960s
ended 14 years before I was born it's
been a long time and you've got all
these young people who have this
glorified version of what happened at
Woodstock which is basically a bunch of
hippies smoking dope and screwing each
other in the mud and this is supposed to
be some sort of great and glorious point
in American history but now we're gonna
revitalize that we're gonna we're gonna
make all of that come back through our
through our hip Ness you know I don't
think that's the case and I think that
this constant search for a cause is not
good particularly when you don't even
know what the causes are that you are
talking about the song itself super
catchy but you should always know what
it is that you are watching and
listening to or at least the messages
that they are trying to portray I mean
there's a more obvious one right you see
a Hindu guy burning a copy of Infowars
the idea being everyone on the right is
an Infowars Alex Jones reader so I
assume this guy is a Sikh in any case
the embedded messages and a lot of these
songs are a little bit are a little bit
hard to spot but this one was very
purposefully put in there the crew the
creative director Jason again him Jason
Krieger he said quote we love the idea
of presenting the apathetic decadent
rebel just for kicks from the song
against a hidden message of resistance
he says this is a real practical laundry
list of ways you can get out there and
fight injustice so just understand that
the pop culture is trying to push a
particular point of view the reason
they're trying to hide it is because if
you know they're trying to push a
particular point of view they're not
good at doing it Katy Perry pushing a
particular point of view and I kissed a
girl and I liked it is much more
effective than Katy Perry onstage at the
DNC speaking on behalf of Hillary
Clinton okay we will be back here
tomorrow with all of the latest breaking
news i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]